hey everyone its Johanna here and always
emphasize how important it is to have
your breakfast in the morning to kick
start your day and I know it can be
difficult especially for those of us who
are busy and the last thing we want to
think about is to make a healthy
breakfast so I've decided to share with
you some of my really easy
make-ahead breakfast which you can prep
over the weekends and this will last you
the entire week this are all really
simple ingredients really quick to make
give it a smell and the look of it right
now it's making me hungry and they would
definitely brighten up your entire week
let's start with my favorite make-ahead
breakfast which is my egg muffin this
egg muffin a packed full of protein from
the egg and the chicken roll I've used
and also you're getting some vegetables
that you need as well as the cheese on
top of it they're so adorable so easy to
eat and each one of them only has one
hundred and twenty three point five
calories so if you like savory food for
your breakfast or if you like to have
eggs in your breakfast this is for you
the ingredients you need are 6 4 X 5
finely sliced chicken rolls or ham or
even any other protein that you prefer
50 gram of kale or spinach or other
leafy vegetables 20 grams of grated
cheese 40 grams of carrots finely slice
again choose another vegetables that you
like such as tomatoes and 1 TSP of olive
oil the first step is to lightly stir
fry your kale and carrots until softened
for about 5 minutes
then add your chicken roll mix them all
up and remove the mix ingredients from
the heat in the meantime
pre-heat your oven to 180
of 350 farenheit next step whisk six
whole eggs get a muffin tray and
transfer your mixed vegetables
ingredients into the muffin tray evenly
once that's done pour your egg mixture
into the muffin tray and just top it up
with your grated cheese all you'll need
to do now is to place your muffin tray
into the oven for 10 minutes and you'll
have your egg muffin and here is your
protein pack and muffin what I tend to
do is to pack those up individually in
an aluminum foil and place them in the
freezer every morning just take them out
remove them from the foil and just warm
them up in the microwave and you have
your breakfast ready it is as simple as
that so try it out
if you like to have pastries bread
scones muffins for breakfast then this
is for you what I have here are banana
muffins you don't have to use bananas
you can choose any other of your
favorite fruits the great thing about
this recipe is that there is no flour
and there is no added sugar at all so
they are basically packed with healthy
ingredients to kickstart your day the
ingredients you need are to the cup of
oats which is about 60 grow to medium
very ripe bananas meshed 1/2 cup of
unsweetened applesauce which is about
243 grab 2 large eggs 1/2 a cup of Greek
yogurt which is about 125 gram 1
teaspoon of vanilla extract 1 tablespoon
of baking powder quarter teaspoon of
baking soda 45 gram of coarsely chopped
almond nuts or any other nuts seeds or
dried fruits of your choice so the first
step is to mix the dry ingredients
together so add your oats baking powder
baking soda and almond nuts into a bowl
and just mix them all up the second step
is to add your wet ingredients so
measure bananas up mix it up with Greek
yogurt break 2 large eggs and continue
to mix it add your applesauce and
finally add one teaspoon of vanilla
extract and make sure they're all evenly
mixed then combine your dry ingredients
with your wet ingredients and mix them
all up evenly
in the meantime pre-heat your oven to
200 degrees Celsius or 400 degrees
Fahrenheit spray the bottom of the
muffin cup with a little bit of cooking
spray to avoid the banana muffin from
sticking finally transfer the mixture
into charm muffin cups allow it to cook
in the oven for 15 minutes once it's
cooked remove it and let it cool for 10
minutes so here are your banana muffins
for the entire week you can place half
of this in the freezer and another half
you can store them into a container and
place them in the fridge
this banana muffins are really soft and
moist but you're getting the crunchiness
from the nuts and each of them only has
105 calories so you can choose to have
to fear breakfast or you can mix them up
have one banana muffin and one egg
muffin if you're really in a rush
you can always pack them and bring it
out with you and have it on the way to
school all work I tend to cook oats in
the morning and have them for my
breakfast but if you don't have the time
try this out this is an overnight OT
yogurt parfait there is no cooking
required it's just basically assembling
your boat
yogurt and your fruits store it in the
fridge and it's ready to be eaten the
next day it's refreshing and it would
definitely fill you up the ingredients
you need are half the cup of Greek
yogurt which is about 125 grams 1/3 cup
of oats which is about 30 gram 2 tbsp of
milk I use soya milk which is about 30
ml 1 cup of frozen berries which is
about 150 gram or any other fresh fruits
of your choice and half a tablespoon of
mixed seeds so what we want to do is to
mix the Greek yogurt oats milk and mix
it into a bowl and now it's time to
assemble your ot yogurt parfait
you can choose to paste it in a jar
which will last you up to 5 days or you
can place it in a cup just like what I'm
doing so the first layer is to place
your yogurt mixture add your frozen
berries place another layer of yogurt
mixture and finally as your frozen
berries and just place it into the
fridge when you leave it in the fridge
overnight what happens is that the
frozen yogurt with all and
the sweetness of the berries will sit
into the yogurt and into the oats as
well so what you'll have is a really
creamy texture with lots of natural
sweetness coming from the berries if you
have a really busy day ahead and you
don't have time for snack like your
breakfast hub with ingredients that will
keep you satisfied unto lunchtime and
finally the breakfast that is highly
sugar which will boosts your energy and
lift your mood up this chewy energy bars
are only made with three ingredients 1
cup of pitted dates which is about 150
gram 1 cup of raisins or any other dried
fruits which is also about 150 gram one
cut off two core cashew nuts or any
other preferred nuts which is about 140
gram all you'll need to do is place
these three ingredients into the food
processor and grind them if you have a
really powerful food processor you will
have a really fine mixture my mixture is
rather coarse but that's fine the next
step is to place your sticky mixture
onto a thin layer of plastic and just
press it down and make a large block
once you have a nice large block slice
it up into 10 smaller blocks and stack
them up by separating them with a thin
layer of plastic these energy bars are
really soft and chewy packed full of
natural sugar so if you feel down or low
in energy and you need a quick sugar
rush choose these snack bars instead of
any other chunks each one of these bars
has 183 degrees this cheery snack bars
can be stored in your food cupboard or
you can store them in the fridge again
feel free to mix and match your
breakfast so take the time over the
weekends buy the ingredients you need
decide which breakfast you would like to
make make them store them in the fridge
or in the freezer take them out the next
day
warm them up and you have
your healthy breakfast to kick-start
your day this breakfast will give you
lots of energy it's good to your body
and you will put a smile on your face so
try them out let me know what you think
in the comments below for new Fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you